[Music]
How are you? Cristián Cáceres greets you with
his short news report on Kirchner in
Spanish The Las Vegas Metropolitan Police are
investigating a fight that escalated to
a shootout and left one person dead A
total of one person died and six
were injured in this incident
those six people two are in
critical health this shooting happened in
five suites near the university
center and flamingo the authorities are
still on the trail of the
suspects anyone with more
information is asked to please
call crime stoppers on the phone and do not  They have a
screen 70 23 85 55 55 and well I remember
that until this morning there are still many
doubts about the shooting on Thursday that
involved the FBI and
the Las Vegas Metropolitan Police. The police
say that this incident began as an
entrenchment at a residence
near  world by ian however the fbi
confirmed that one person was
shot and that it was a shooting that
involved one of his  us agents the victim is still
recovering from this incident
and mascar is finally here in las
vegas different cars drove through the set
last night as they do annually there you
have the images on your screen the
nascar of service champion kyle austin
was the one who led this caravan
We will have full coverage on
our social networks and also on
our website at news now
dotcom and we close the week with a
cloudy day and a little colder than the
last few days. Here we present the
forecast for the weekend with
temperatures in the  60 degrees that
we are monitoring a system that can
bring rain to the region and snow to
the mountains I am Cristian you will marry your
great informative Spanish naval news
good day
[Music]